після розвалу у льодові коаліції з посади
рига че тут в Україні заговорили про
такий собі олігархічний переворот ви
поділіть думку я б сказала ще стала
тобто очевидним темп про що зігнали
завали багаті на українських журналістів
розслідувати чого daikin народні
депутати з блоку Петра Порошенка та
опозиційного блоку із відра janym
голосував і так все складу цього виразу
на явності пивному за віскоза олігархами
такі знаки та
і я вважаю ще їх три сприймати
серйозно в канді як profinet і впливали
гірчичних кладемо на українську політику
про якість гадаю slide і чи треба нам
агат є і політику та економіку варіанта
ват ян та інь чи засідки а сам залишатися
непоміченим і вид у пливу пивних
монополіям так-то олігархи в атаку ж
вид корупції
там ще багатий ще україни пов'язані з
корупцією і c задаєш skoda палить цим
skoda краї не економити і а чим а адже
на вашу думку парламентарія кіпр ахнути
реформ ще шанс прикро тиснути на нову
широку коаліцію на сам перед я почищу
волоки фракції як блок Петра Порошенка та
народний фронт все ж таки на магу юті і дали
спи проти ти навіть прикрий вікна men ще
inci менше сильної фракції самодопомога
то батьківщина вийшла з quality
я шановні миші лося не стиль кіпру
потреби країни абель shop расові парті
не інтересу та амбіції all обожнювання троянда
висновок околицю дали випив проти ти у
тих про європейських kill
economy але в принципі на явні карти цієї
концепції
тому що європа мужиче мало ще акти
ніша Петро їм його ти реформаторські сили
в україні sound залишитися
макан імана можна чекати роботою більше
червона згарища самий з ерік ясна і rock
am cool і буде рублів ну дуже багато
заводіть подалі і фінансовий Петро
ринку pro-active закривав кут easy
децентралізації адаптації то
імплементації біля води про асоціацію з
конкрет подалі Петро in canada вати
метті і саме сюди парламент до
ідеальності роботи фракції сосу
пробувала не dimon будувати падіння ременя
тавера їжу арсеній яценюк пеклі
абсолютного мінімуму на вашу doom купою
і в нього як у глави уряду ще шанс шоу
виходить з таких негативних результатів
wap це не вік завищуються на низькому та
ревнивши ж плану дрік вин міг би зарубати
і відповіді виставки обсмажуємо до віри
народу хай не буду його політики та їх
уккари поза сти навіть за менші вся
факту вин міг би зруби цієї виставки та
піт і самий алсу бисто думка таким кроком
можна було б у льоту води та низку коаліцію
і билин пішов у вигляд став cut звивини в
б місця для курсу яншо вам хто милий би
сформувати і цей і ряди нових людей
даремно що і таким чином
і c за моїм кримінальним цим за втечу ти
новим парламентським виборам тіла руку
чини були вибори виходом із політичні
щури легше прем'єрний діу вид ставку і
легше президент закриття верховну раду
саморозпуску тис а то нам хіт не будучи
нові вибори
all і виходу з щурів і вирішенням проблеми
у неоднозначній e&k і спливши на ваше
моя президент порошенко нове рішення у
льодові щури президент нас правді
повинен дати і низку свободу рішень ідей
ми з весну знаємо ще з ну я багатий у
зірок київ та спливу
а обличчі та дуалізм дикі на явні в
україні mesh президентом то прем'єром але
громада більше ворога висновок і замість
президент шкіряних моя влада не завдання
такому потенцію гадаю на ступні місити їм
найбільша посилана до епоні бауман дякую вам
за розмиву